[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
what's going on chat
pretty sure you guys can hear me not
confident not a hundred percent but i'm
pretty sure you guys can hear me what's
going on man i appreciate every coming
through we're going to be getting going
here
momentarily in about eight minutes i'm
still waiting on uh the whole panel to
show up you know i'm sure they'll show
up here soon also we'll be a couple
minutes late um but you know he's he has
some uh work stuff he has to do but
he'll be here soon
hopefully um
you know we we got a pretty good show
man we got a pretty good show uh you
know once we start this man i'm pretty
sure some of you gonna like this uh this
show i got going for you
here
probably in the next week we'll have the
artwork up i do plan on um
changing the format up of the show a
little bit if that makes sense to you
guys we'll talk about that here in a
little bit later but appreciate it for
coming through definitely
stick around for a good show like i said
hustle will be a little late
and i'll see you here in a couple
minutes
here we go
so
what's going on you guys
sorry we a little bit late man we had
some technical difficulties originally
so first off let me explain okay uh i
wasn't expecting hustle for a couple
minutes so i had like another template
that showed when hustle showed up but
when he showed up before the podcast i
had to like redo that and then when i
went to
change the properties of where the audio
is coming from it was like we're not
going to show you that uh we're not
going to show you the xbox headset so i
had to like reset that
it's just it's it's it's been chaotic
but anyway thank you guys for coming to
another attic show where we talk about
the past present and future gaming i got
my co-host with me hustle and motivate
what's up go what's going on hustle what
have you been doing what have you been
playing
oh well as far as what i've been playing
uh super smash brothers melee just
messing around with it um
but i brought i don't know where the
hell i put it i bought um
if y'all follow me on twitter you know i
bought a kingdom hearts
heard jay barry talking jay barry you
know aristotle was talking about this on
weapon wheel it kind of was going on and
on about it so
i figure i'll give this a shot and uh
see what the series is hitting for at it
you're into this aren't you yes i've
beat them all
um so carry us when are you going to
start that
probably friday i was going to start
okay okay we we we're going okay saying
this now we're going to have weekly
reports with hustle and kingdom hearts
so we don't have that going on so so is
that all you've been doing man
yeah um outside like the yeah yeah if
you follow me on twitter again uh
probably i don't know if i posted some
pictures of my new privacy gate me and
my pops put up privacy game for the dogs
so they out there running around having
a good time um this just been with the
dogs mainly though outside of that just
working home and here we are
and then we got a good friend i was on
his podcast a couple months ago court
how do you say your whole name corey
ledour like i don't want butcher man
like it's it's it's fr it's french
canadian it's uh
see i can barely speak english after the
time so that's definitely not happening
okay yeah they it wouldn't remember
actually uh in the u.s i get lalonde or
la lande a lot but uh it it's lalone
lalonde whatever whatever you want to do
it don't bother me it's i said
but like i'm a card court
that's easier that's so much easier yeah
but i felt like the first time people
had to know your official name and as
people see when i'm reading super chats
i can't pronounce stuff to save my life
uh so you you're gonna say your name
because i could barely speak english at
the time i ain't going nowhere near some
french stuff ain't happening
i'm with you there um when we do xbox
and we're reading off the uh the article
sometimes we're trying to give the
writer we're like and this is written by
you're like yeah i'm gonna butcher this
and i'm gonna try but i'm like yeah i
give up i've i've been uh hit too many
times playing hockey um
i say words wrong a lot
it's just it is what it is
great to you hustle on uh trying to
kingdom hearts because uh
that story had me lost but i did like
the last one i played it i even just
recently replayed it when it was on game
pass with my daughter who's five and she
loved every minute of it because she has
no clue what's going on just like
everybody's playing it it's got good
gameplay i will say that
five
uh kingdom hearts three has the best
game play by far like
by far
you'll see it when you get to
hustle i know you about to hurt like
kingdom hearts one is clunky
it's yeah
yeah but maybe no worse than uncharted
one like that oh i'm telling you no
kingdom hearts won i'm just like the
beginning like the first you know what's
gonna happen you're gonna play four
hours and be like you're gonna message
yeah attic and be like so when am i
gonna get to play this game like what is
what's going on here well i'm okay i'm
glad you brought it up so i'm treating
this like persona um
when i first played persona 5 for the
very first time is it coming with
individual games or is that just
it looks like that that binder looks
huge yes too oh okay okay okay
yeah so i'm just going to try to like
persona though they said uh it's all
it's jrpg so you really don't expect
that in the first few hours that you
play so you just got to kind of get the
it's the introductory stage so i'm gonna
just treat it like that and um hopefully
it'll turn up but if it is bad if it is
bad or if if the controls are clunky i'm
gonna forgive it because it came out in
like two thousand and like five right it
came out like it came out during the ps2
era so i i'm not gonna like hold it to
such a high standard you know what i'm
saying when three came out i was like
yeah was this was this uh
is this made for last gen but it's still
fun
it's just you could you could tell it
was it was it was an old game even when
it came out well i i played it when it
came out so it looked very visually
impressive back then when it first came
out uh so let me ask you a question real
quick hustle are you interested in
playing that game in the order that they
were actually released or in the order
the story releases them in
so
i know we got like uh
i saw a shout out to jimmy at jmega
games he was over at weaponry he had
this for a patreon request there's like
a movie with this so i'm gonna yeah i'm
gonna look it up online and see where i
actually start well there's a in the 2.0
on one point uh the 2.5 and 1.5 the
third game is is just the cut scenes
it's not the game itself
which is weird but you know yeah i think
it's because they were like game boy
games or something like that i don't
know
uh but you know
i if i were you i would start with birth
by sleep that's the one i would start
with
okay you said birth by sleep yes it's
how many of their total
i i don't know the lore there's like 18
or 9 i was joking with someone just the
other day i was like someone needs to
explain it to me like i'm five just just
tell me like a five and explain it to me
is there fun games
this is birth birth by sleep
uh final mix is that what you're doing
yes that's the one you want to do all
right i'll start there we have some fun
yeah that's the one you want to start on
and the reason you want to start there
is i don't that's not technically the
first one in the origins but i think
that's the first one that you would like
that would explain the story better the
problem with kingdom hearts is
it's not that the story is confusing
it's that the story is told through
multiple platforms
and multiple games throughout like 15 20
years they'll hit you with the you know
kingdom hearts once technically like the
third kingdom hearts birth by sleeps
technically like the second and they
came out like 10 years apart from each
other so
that's the reason that game's confusing
it feels like star wars yeah if you went
from kingdom hearts one to two you
missed a game between them but they
don't really do a good job explaining
that like a lot of other games when it
comes to
you know explaining stuff with sequels
the sequels aren't really important you
know what i'm saying like they never
really continue stories and games with
sequels it's always like a prequel or
something like all of the games in
kingdom hearts is explaining kingdom
hearts lore but they don't do a good job
explaining that
um
either turn me in court up or turn
yourself down
i'll turn you guys up
but yeah that's pretty much all man like
it's not that the game's bad
uh it's just
at the end of the day
i do feel like they could have done it
what i don't like about kingdom hearts
is just like the cringe part that's all
like like some of the writing is bad
like i don't even like the story makes
sense to me because i've played them all
but the but even know that the story
makes sense to me the the the script and
the dialogue sometimes is so cringe
worthy like
it's it's unreal man
it put a smile on my daughter's face
when i was like when i was on game pass
and we were like she loves the hercules
movie she likes frozen and all that so i
would like purposely like
get to those levels then i'm just like
all right just go have fun yes go live
in that world go have fun because like
she she really liked the frozen roll
even though it was like opposite of what
the movie is and i was actually
explaining today that they originally
were going with the original disney
script when they designed the level and
then had to change everything because
disney decided that elsa wasn't going to
be the bad guy anymore because that's
the original movie elsa was a bad guy
and they decided to not make her that so
then they had to switch it around and
they were already making kingdom hearts
the game so they're like okay let's just
figure it out and we pitch and hold they
change the script so like that whole
section doesn't make sense but she loved
like toy story level oh my god i think
my daughter she could play that for
hours
and do nothing just run it around
all right so let me get this super chat
real quick we got a two dollar superdrug
from drawn tj
hey guys what's going on uh drawing
what's up tj all right so first off you
know enough kingdom hearts talking about
some people in this chat already falling
asleep uh so we're gonna we got a good
show for you guys man we got xbox game
pass you know i do feel like uh there
are some things that we need to talk
about xbox game pass we got xbox out
selling the ps5 and we got certain
infiniti helping with halo which is
interesting because they're working on
another game as well but you know we'll
get into that later on in the show you
know first thing i want to i want to ask
the guests what do you want to talk
about first
well uh if we're if we're doing it uh
xbox i think we have to talk about game
pass because let's just talk about game
pass first it's it's it's literally the
thing that
i don't know i know it's the most
divisive and now at the same time with
playstation doing their premium tiers
that they're pretty much doing the same
without doing the same but
i can't get over the fact of how good a
deal is and i just we were talking
before the show a game like mlb the show
which is made by san diego studios which
is a sony first party studio
launches day and date on game pass and
it's the most downloaded game
[Music]
and not even by a little bit like it's
crushing everybody right now and it
doesn't get talked about enough like
it's just like what forza dropped forza
to me almost was game of the year and
now mlb the show was dropping on game
pass and everybody's like oh well yeah i
know it's all on playstation i'm like
but xbox is literally
every couple months dropping huge games
on game pass
and it seems to be there's more of like
okay you're either on one side or the
other why can't people just be just
happy to be a gamer i'm so confused that
the the visceral like surrounds game
pass it confuses me
well i think what it is is you know
there's a
select group of people uh do me a favor
hustle while we're doing this find the
games that came out this month for a
game pass
all righty when it comes down to i think
people are so obsessed with discrediting
one service
that they don't give any props to the
other vice versa like i've always said
that like
playstation now
is a good service
but the problem was is sony didn't
support it
so you can't really fl like fluctuate
and do good when when you're when the
person that owns you isn't doing nothing
like that's equivalent like what they
were doing is equivalent like when a
game comes out like a huge third-party
game they give it to playstation plus
instead of now which never made sense to
me
and you know you that's that's
equivalent to microsoft putting their
third-party games like tunic and stuff
on games with gold instead of place
instead of games uh instead of um game
pass which you know that if you think
about that you have a service that you
spent all this money on and you're not
putting games in their end date it'd be
different if you wasn't doing it at all
but they're putting those games on
another service that's not playstation
now and i think that was the biggest
issue of playstation now and i think
since they've combined them now i don't
think you're going to see that issue as
much because
they let's be real this what this was
and what what sony was wanting to
achieve
is playstation now wasn't as being like
anywhere near as successful as game pass
so they put them together to make all
the numbers one and you know that that's
a genius move and i feel like now since
playstation now and plus you're combined
i think you're going to see them put a
lot more money behind that surface
you're going to see more third-party
indie games and more third-party games
in general come out day and day one of
the biggest things that you know you're
talking about the show that i was
confused about was like why did you not
put
mlb the show on playstation now
like because at this point i feel like
what are you really making off of that
game to justify not doing it you know
what i'm saying like and from a
competitive aspect why aren't you trying
to compete with them on the games that
you can compete with them i understand
not the god of wars i understand you
know you know the horizon forbidden west
but it's mlb the show they they're gonna
have one next year and the one year
after that like i feel like that should
be a yearly installment going straight
to playstation now
well i i don't disagree with you i i
look at the numbers so mlb the show 2017
was 1.16 million 2018 was 1.06 they
don't have the numbers for 19 or 20. so
if they're only selling that many in
sales
um then yeah i don't understand why it
wasn't on there but can we go back to
can we sunset xbox live gold and just
make that go away can xbox just listen
and just go away hey do what like i i've
seen this is the new one i see on you
know what would be crazy if they did
that with xbox go they combined it them
in that too well they did the same thing
that playstation does
and then their subscriber count would be
that like because that's what i'm seeing
is the new argument everybody's like
well the playstation playstation now has
already had more subscribers like well
yes sort of because they're combining
the two and they're making one but sure
but i think they're both good services
and both have their advantages i think
the the biggest downfall i have for
playstation now
is the
playstation 3 games are only played
during streaming and i think that's a
problem
oh yeah facts um but i will go over a
few of these games um
and uh shout out to xbox they need to
really change
hustle if you don't mind yeah hold on
this is my game rant but i got y'all
done i get i get the you know the the
mindset with that
it's just like to me at this point
you're not offering anything with games
with gold
that just needs to and i think what it
is too the reason they don't want to get
rid of it is because it is
subconsciously putting value on the
service even though that it's not good
it's still putting value to it i'm just
like
maybe maybe the casuals like these games
but when i look at these games i'm like
i can't realistically seeing too many
people download these games
i i'm not gonna lie i downloaded this
this once i downloaded spongebob but i
downloaded it from my five-year-old
daughter so there's like is there's a
difference like that's different i think
spongebob is an actual gem that they did
and they also have done a couple lego
games just recently but other than that
they're just xbox 360 games
don't get me wrong i like playing my
backwards compact games um i do love the
fact that i can download them like i
have tried i am in an area where there
is good internet and um
i've tried in batter in areas around me
that have bad internet to try and play
stream games and that's just ain't for
me i i need to download the game so for
me the biggest advantage game pass has
is it gives you an option to play the
game how you want to play it for every
game so like whenever we do on xbox a
we're announcing we do the the
playstation uh the game pass games for
april we announced we're like this game
comes to a cloud pc console cloud pc
console cloud like they just they're
making sure if you look at their release
schedule and we'll go over right now
they're making sure that every single
game comes to everything so you can
either play it on your phone you'll play
on your pc you play in the cloud or you
can play it on your console
i do want to say this though i think the
reason why they still offer gold is just
really just to push people to game pass
anyway um it's kind of like adding i
know we was talking about this i think
it was last week we were talking about
uh playstation plus or the playstation
like now service and we saw that middle
tables like why is the middle tier there
it's really to push people either to the
essential for playstation or the premium
for playstation so i think that's why
games with gold is still there yeah it
would be nice if they kind of rolled it
all in in the one i think they might do
that if anything you see
if what's up they might
compete with sony how they're doing
stuff and combine this because they've
always loved the fact that they were
doing more than playstation they might
not come out openly and say that but
they like look you might be beating us
in the console market but we destroy you
in the subscription market but now since
sony's combined these two subscription
services they're they're actually ahead
of of game pass so i feel like you might
see some restructuring going on with
that
and someone in the chat mentioned like
if sony did date yeah 100 if sony does
day and date third-party games
that's that is that is finally a
competitor to game pass i just don't see
them ever doing it anytime soon um maybe
eight months down the road after the
game release maybe gets dropped but
they're gonna want like just the
comments that they have made publicly
like they're like well first they used
to say it wasn't financially viable they
even do a subscription service now
they're saying it is but it won't be
financially viable to do our first
pretty first-party games to drop so
that's probably why attic they didn't
put on mlb the show because they
couldn't that that would be
contradicting to literally a statement
that they put out saying that they can't
do it
so what was you going to say how so
sorry i interrupted you there i know you
start your story um i was going to tell
you the list of the games that came in
so they got a
let me make sure i'm back on it oh no
this is what i don't like about what
xbox does they offer you like half the
games that like the last half of the
month and it carries over to the next
half of the month or it's like from like
april it's like from march 15th to april
15th i don't like that that's
that's all that they never think about
one day i think they all should come up
yes sir i feel like like i get you but i
think the reason they do that is because
that's that's marketing there like they
have steady
reasons to be in the news that you know
i feel like that's the point like sure
they could drop it all in one day but
first off
i think that would be disturbance to the
actual indies and stuff in the service
if they're just dropped with a bunch of
games at the same time like i think they
kind of like try to give them that time
to shine too where if you have a couple
games dropping like two to three every
couple weeks or every week you have a
better chance at those games being
looked at than you just dropped 15 in
one day
yeah and also they got the day and dates
right like if you look at that'll be the
show
it came out you could do they do have a
great service where mlb the show is one
of the games you're going to talk about
they had it so that
people that had game pass could still
get the early a lot of games to early
release so any day game that has early
release you'll still be able to buy that
extra
little chunk it to pay half of what
someone would if you wanted to buy the
whole version here in canada for example
it was 109
to get the day and date early version so
you're playing it four days early well
you only had to pay
60 dollars
if you had game pass already and you got
it four days early um unless yeah that's
that's that is good um
man look
i'm i'm one of my guests attic did you
wanna read that super chat yeah we got a
ten dollar sweep shot from the iron
lords podcast how are you going to super
chat your own account that's kind of
funny don't trust that court guy cool to
see xbox in on the attic show that's my
dude salute big hustle and young wolf
okay back to work talk to you later cog
appreciate the uh uh thank you for the
kind words the the stepping in and
talking there for a second you know he's
at the gym right he's just like he's
just like looking he's got it up he's
like he's doing some doing some sets
he's like all right i'll put one have
you ever seen like
the the the
there's like a thing on facebook and
uh
and twitter right now where some dude is
on like he's golfing and he's got this
this like contraption that's setting the
camera up to look at him he's got a
green screen behind him and he's
pretending to be in a uh he's pretending
to be in some kind of meeting or
something like that and every time like
he crouches down a little bit you see
the
background a little bit i was like i
could see like like cognito do with that
like okay you know because he he works a
lot so he's like i'm gonna have to find
a way to do this gym so he's he's doing
these meetings and he's like he's bench
pressing and they're just seeing the bar
and that's all
no you walk into his gym and he's
running on the treadmill with an oculus
on and he's doing the meeting inside the
oculus you're just running on the
treadmill actually cognito just
responded in the chat he said he's
actually between sets all right cognito
slow down i might have to hit the gym i
understand what you i feel like that's a
shot at me like i just need to hit the
gym he said what's up big hustler he had
to call me big
i'm six three two fifty you know what
you're doing kyle but no no it's cause
it's good to see you man um
well
but as far as a few of these gameplays
games they got life is strange true
colors which i have actually been told
that's a good game
yeah i've i have it sitting there it's
just i haven't turned it on
is it uh oh i have a question about that
game is it uh is it like the first life
of strange the well i may cry a little
bit keep it right
from what i understand yes yes okay
we'll see okay we'll see um what is lost
in the random well so lawson random is a
is a turn-based game um from ea and uh
co-host of my other podcast i do on
wednesday's um three dads waba loved
that game it was actually up there
before when it's game of the years loved
it
okay all right and uh
wait
wait
i have them do you want me to say them
yes please because i can barely see that
as it were we got a cricket
22. uh that's okay
i saw that yeah yeah i saw that how are
you gonna say ill
it's atticus cricket okay hold on hold
on so court you you are from you know
north you are from the great north yeah
do do you guys participate in chris i
know y'all know y'all playing hockey but
um do y'all participate in cricket
i've never personally played it but
there is a large uh cricket fandom here
in in uh the toronto area yes um
okay real quick just a set of settled
something for me because i don't know
are those games like six hours long or
something uh 100 they are forever um i
don't watch them on tv it's not my thing
but i i know people that love it
and i was playing i my first job star i
started my first job and we were playing
softball and uh one of the gentlemen's
on our on our team
he grew up um not in canada but he used
to play qriket back home so when we were
playing baseball we're playing softball
he's out there with no glove i'm like
i'm like dude you gotta wear a glove
he's like i don't need no glove and no
he did not he's jumping up catching fly
balls no problem with this thing when
you go watch a cricket match these guys
are catching a very heavy ball hit very
hard with no gloves i see you crazy
like too far apart from each other you
can catch if he had gloves on maybe it
would slip off your hand a little bit
better
um but real quick the only time that
they really showed in america um because
i watched a frequent espn is that when
those games go from like
like 18 hour games that's why i asked
about the length of the games and stuff
but they
yeah they'll have those moments too
where they'll like carry over for a
super long time i never really
understood it never really got into it
you'll never see me doing the uh cricket
thing man oh yeah i'm not i'm not i'm
not i don't need another game to play i
i play uh golf because i'm i'm old and
that's what i do on the summer time on
the weekends i used to play hockey until
i had a lot of concussions and
but i'll play baseball video games and
uh hockey video games no problem
time i see people playing hockey i just
feel like that that's a dangerous sport
man
it is getting close line doing two or
three backflips man i feel like i it's
crazy how physical that is but you know
we'll go back into you know as far as
game pass you know i think what game
pass does really well and i don't think
a lot of people understand this you know
sometimes it's dry on xbox let's be real
here sometimes they don't have games
coming out for months at a time but i
don't think what people that don't game
on game pass and people that don't have
game pass or not even have an xbox in
general understand is it's hard to
complain that it's dry
when they're giving you games to try out
and you can like them and you end up
playing those games the entire month
and then before you know it you're like
oh this game's cool i remember grant um
generation something echo generation
that game came out in game pass a couple
months ago made in china canada yeah and
so i'm playing it i ended up playing
that for like two weeks straight so it
people don't understand that like when
you give your consumer something to do
it's hard to complain there's nothing to
do
and that's what playstation's missing
because when it's dry on playstation
it's just dry
like unless you're going to play
third-party games that you wouldn't
normally play
and the reason that game pass is so good
is because you could buy
the third-party stuff by the games that
you're hyped for but every gamer unless
you like you play literally every genre
there's going to be a couple months out
of the year that
you either
touch the backlog that you keep telling
yourself you're going to play and you
never do
or you try something new because people
want that new experience if you dropped
a game nine times i just said you're not
going back to that game and if you do
you'll play another 10 15 minutes of it
and you drop it again
and people want that new experience and
game pass is like a door that you like
you push a lever back and it spins a
room and it just gives you a new
experience and if you like it you don't
and if you do like it you play and if
you don't like it you spin the knob
again
and now for you
the developers of echo generation the
next time they have a game and it gets
announced you're gonna be like oh i
remember playing it whether it's on game
ass or not you're now going to think
about it i will buy them
so that
they're a fantastic developer um
that game i i'm just like you i loved it
and it was also great because there was
a lot of canadiana in it so like there
was a lot of like inside canada jokes um
but
i 100 agree with you i think it helps so
much for the indie developers
there are so many games that i have
played on game pass that i never would
have tried
but because they're on game pass i'm
like all right i need a filler game
because usually what happens is i'll
have whatever game i'm playing like
right now i'm playing lego star wars i'm
also playing m will be the show i always
have a game pass game on the side
going at all times i have
um
other games that i've thought about
playing but i'll keep them in my play
play later and then i also look at games
what game can i play on my phone like
echo generation was one of those ones
like alright it works on my phone that
game definitely could work i remember
like phoenix point i played that for
like three weeks and i still haven't
beat that game that's like the only xcom
style game that has defeated me
like
i got to the point where after i
restarted that game about eight or nine
times i was like i'm done i don't want
this smoke anymore and that's why i
think that you know people don't
understand look game pass i don't care
what people say there are certain games
that if it is their day and date it's
going to lower the the sales and that's
just strictly because people are buying
it and you know people like oh well this
developer said it increased their sales
well okay your point like you can't tell
me that halo infinite was what is sold
more if halo infinite wasn't in game
pass but the thing is just because
there's that negative stick but what you
did probably have a decline in sales
doesn't mean that game pass isn't
helping the xbox ecosystem in general
it's helping them with relations when it
comes to
indies because there's nothing more that
will get indies on your back like y'all
give you some money
and uh you just put your game on this
and you know let's be real here a lot of
these indies know that their game isn't
going to sell like to that point where
they don't need to put it on this on the
service and like you said it gives you
it gives it gives them clout because if
they make a good game and it goes in
game pass they're always going to be
looking at that game from now on oh man
that's made by i remember moonlighters
with people who made moonlighters their
games getting bought next time they made
moonlighters and i bought their next
expansion two moonlighters if it wasn't
in game pass i wouldn't have played
moonlighters i wouldn't convince three
other people to buy moonlighters and i
wouldn't have bought the expansion for
moonlighters well the the stats came out
and we i we talked about in our previous
episode matt and i
they already showed that people that use
game pass buy more games
than people that didn't previously like
if you were just someone that's on sony
you're gonna buy this game in this game
but what you're on when you have game
pass you're like oh well i already have
all these games i'm like all right you
know what i'll try this game or i'll try
this game oh this big like um this big
indie game comes out you're like oh i
got to try buying that game anyways you
end up spending more money and i think
this is going gonna happen for sony too
because when playstation now launches
and it's the full shebang
we're now as gamers gonna have such an
amazing time to be a gamer you're gonna
be like well i can either have i can
have both services and i can just play
hopefully everything either launches on
one or the other and that's how you
choose where you're going to play it
and it kind of has the reverse effect on
me um i know once you buy a game from
game pass you get a discount on it
typically if i like a game like i like
physical media attica tell you that so
typically if i like a game from off the
game pass like the outer worlds
i like that game and i do want to own a
copy of it i might not be able to play
for like another week and a half before
i'm starting this but like a month
well hey look i'll get through one of
those games and i'll get back to the
other worlds but my point is i am
enjoying it and um and that game is like
fairly cheap now anyway um so instead of
me paying i think it was like sixty
dollars on steam so instead of me paying
the 16 on steam i just finally used copy
somewhere because i'm enjoying it that
much you know and then if my game pass
i'm saving on pc eventually just so
happily it's elapsed i still got the
other game in my possession so yeah so
i like game pads for that because it's a
it's a good like a rental
rental service
options like i bought control after it
left game pass i've never got around her
i kept in my play later and then they
then i read we did a show and it was
like oh controls leaving i'm like oh my
god i haven't played and like remedy is
when i was like i've got to try this
game and i'm like you know what
i went online i went on my my best buy
and i bought a physical copy of the the
full version because the game passed
version didn't have the you know the 4k
everything the
full glow up for the xbox series x so i
just bought for 14.99 i bought the full
version and i got a physical property
control control ended up being even
though it was a game came out years ago
it was my favorite game i played last
year
and
another thing that i don't really see
people look too much when it comes to
game pass
is
it does help games like certain certain
games that wouldn't have done this like
outriders you guys honestly think
outriders would have been the miley
success it was without game pass like i
don't feel like people were gonna
gravitate towards that game like me
personally i tried it but like i always
when it comes to like making that
destiny vein type of game uh that's why
i was laughing when people say destiny
killer because the only thing that can
kill destiny is destiny and it's just
like
when it comes to something like
outriders you know that they said that
what's um
guardians of the galaxy
they said that there's more people
that's been playing guard in the galaxy
since it came out in game pass
then before it came out then you got
stuff like you know uh outriders
outriders was a success because of
something like game pass because when
you're playing on a especially a cross
platform game and you're playing
something like outriders and like yo
this game's kind of funny like yo
where'd you get i got in game pass man
i'm on playstation well you better you
better knock up that 59.99 that's 69.99
and
if there's anyone that like look
marketing could sell games
uh you know watching something on the
super bowl can sell games advertising on
tick tock can sell games advertising on
youtube could sell games but you know
what sells games way more than any of
those
friends to friends they can you can
convince your friend to buy the most
dog-stuffed game that's ever been
existence and when they play you know
what you know you know how i know when
you play a game and the words come out
of your friend's mouth man if i buy this
are we actually going to play it like am
i if i buy this one we actually going to
play it like yeah man
go ahead get it man we going to play
this tonight play for like an hour and a
half never touch that game ever again
it's just like you see this happening
all the time so i can imagine so many
people playing outriders and you know
how it is when you're in a party with
your friends and you're in a group chat
with your friends and everyone's in this
but you you're the only one not playing
outriders everyone in your friends
playing outrights they all have xboxes
you have playstation you're gonna have
to go over there and you have to buy
that full price because you don't have
an xbox and i'm sure that happened i'm
confident that happened where there was
moments where friends were playing these
games and in order to play it with them
they had to buy that full retail price
i actually had to do that sorry my
apologies i know your story you straight
court no no i actually had to do that
because um i i do own all writers on ps5
as a matter of fact i bought the digital
version too and i ain't like it man
that's exactly why i buy the physical
version did your friends tell you guys
were going to play that a lot too
well hey it's all credit we did um
audible shout out to the troubleshooters
and um dallas over there level one we
had ran it and i know me dallas and
famer ran it a couple times too so we we
played it it just this wasn't my thing
honestly that that game could have been
so much more if they gave it more
content and gave it more behind it it it
had such a high level and then it just
it it dropped but i think that is game
pass a secret weapon if you have an xbox
and you have game pass or if you have a
pc and you have game pass you know
whatever game is dropping on game pass
you can play with your friends your
friend doesn't have to be like oh i
gotta go buy that game you'd be like
okay we're gonna download this game
we're all gonna play it tonight and then
boom that's why i think and i think
that's why places got on it because to
me game pass is about community and if
you look at what the a lot of things we
all like to do everybody talks about
tribalism and like the sports teams you
like and all that everyone likes to be a
part of something so when you're on game
pass you feel like you're a part of
something and you get to be like hey no
matter what like mlb the show right now
i know that anybody i know that has an
xbox i'm like hey if you want to go play
this i don't they don't have to go buy
it they just have to download it and it
doesn't hurt them whether they like it
or not they can come on and play i know
when destiny was on there i'm not a big
destiny player sorry to the uh to the
realm but it's uh
i still went on and played like sean
capri with them were playing i'm like
sure i'll download it who cares because
it's accessible
exactly and
play the game i notice people try to
give this negative notation where it's
like if you don't like a game you gain
that you download on game pass you're
just gonna delete it like acting like
that's a negative thing
i can download a game and if i don't
like it i didn't invest anything
financially besides the 15
i'm already subscribed to because of
certain games that come out throughout
the year and i can just delete it if i
don't like it where is the negative in
that there's no negative but for some
reason people want you to think that
because you don't play that game look i
get it if you don't buy a game maybe
subconsciously
if you buy a certain game on for full
price and you're playing it and people
was like well you know you ain't gonna
you you're not gonna continue playing if
you don't like it you're gonna drop it
and i'm thinking myself you know how
many times i forced my game myself
through a game because i didn't like it
or it's not that i didn't like it it
just wasn't hitting 100 ever played a
game that you're playing you're not
really getting too into it but you're
not hating it at the same time and
you're kind of forcing yourself along
the track and it's just like
and do you play these games these type
of games and the thing in the back of
your head's like yo
i'm gonna i got i paid 60 dollars for
this game it's not that i hate it let's
just finish it and you kind of make
yourself finish it you don't have that
that sensation anymore if you don't like
that game it's getting delayed because
you didn't put a penny into it and i
don't see a problem in that
yeah i'm cool on that man if you know if
it's something it's really just
something there for you to try if you
like it you know
cool and if you don't that's cool too
you just you know getting up off the
thing add it you say all that
but you got to play tetris effect i'm
not sure if you played it again oh my
god no you're sorry a tetris effect all
right moving along so uh we well you
know i want to be messy a little bit i
want to be messy okay
godfall has come to gamepad no it's not
game pass it's on xbox
and
it's cheap though it's cheap it's cheap
i feel like xbox should have went for
that for game pass i don't know why par
part of me feels like if a game is
exclusive on playstation when that comes
to to uh to to the xbox platform
microsoft needs to go in the background
like
yo we want this game on on game pass
because i feel like what that does i
don't like game uh godfall i i've never
really like i try to play it to play
like 30 minutes of it it that that type
of uh you know combat doesn't really
entice me too much but i feel like what
you do there is like look you got
exclusivity on this but we're kind of
taking that away and if and if xbox
gamers start seeing that as a trend
they won't get it on the other platform
because people don't realize that when
it comes to
these type of games
what's the most important thing about
console owning is the fact that you'll
be able
to
keep people on your platform for the
most of the games that's what they're
really fighting you over they want you
buying your cards on their platform they
want you buying you know the ubisoft
games the aea games because that is
where they're getting money they sure
they want you to buy the game and play
their games
but that's not the end goal the n goes
they want you buying everything on that
platform and i feel like if xbox really
wants to go in that way you know make it
to where something like bug snacks you
know
okay
i can't believe we're talking about this
game coming to game pass
so god fault i feel like if that would
have come to gain fast and you start
seeing this trend
you know people might not invest into
that that playstation ecosystem as much
because they're like yo
it's coming it's just a matter of when
hey
sorry how many times do you say to you
well you know what i'm not going to buy
it now it's probably going to cover game
pass actually never say that
like on the reel like for the most part
i might say it on like little little
indies or something like that but
something like godfall like anything
like if dragon quest came out i probably
would just buy that you know what i'm
saying if if a final fantasy 7 came out
i would probably just buy that like i
think anyone that comes out and they say
i'm waiting for game pass
they were just
curious about that game they were never
fans of that game if you're fans of that
game you would buy that game day one i'm
very confident to say that if you are
hyped about something you're not waiting
for a game pass version
no i i pre-ordered and i've been playing
lego star wars i got the
in canada games are not cheap here there
it's 90 for the the deluxe version of
lego star wars the digital copy normal
games out here are 90 bucks uh it sucks
but it is what it is well at least i'll
get free health care um shout out to the
floor hug 100 hey we're about to get
free dental
oh man we're not talking about that it's
just gonna whatever we get free
healthcare we're about to get free
dental too
we do pay in taxes but you know what
every every place has you know every
place has its greatness i'm actually a
dual citizen i was actually born in uh
atlanta georgia but uh
but uh i've lived my whole life pretty
much in canada since i was five so i get
the best of both worlds so that's nice
we got a two dollar superchat from flame
addict let's talk about bug stats
hashtag weenie hands i have no clue
where that came from
um oh no that's a
character you can put uh hot dog hands
yeah oh look i'll be real with you
um
i play godfall we'll talk about that the
part that
annoys me the most about godfall is i
play this and i see so much potential
like but it's just like you know maybe
it wasn't properly you know nutrient i
don't know
how that goes because the bug snacks
though
that's not happening it's not happening
i ain't downloading that game that's
good you know
i
i guess you could theoretically download
it for some for some twitter fun you
know if you guys know what i mean but
like even if you want to do that is it
really worth the the the download speed
like you know some people playing caps
on they download speed is it really
worth that like like that game i don't
know man i don't know i feel like i feel
like there's better stuff to download
than bug snaps now uh i wonder if king i
know you're in the chat king
king's moving to canada by the way
king ain't moving nowhere
question
kane
king is going to download bug snacks
just to put it on his twitter
i could just see king now king will
record and be like but like uh he'll say
something like um what was he like to
use he's like uh you guys are the the
beta testers this is where it truly is
that's why everyone loves keyboard
king is is predictable but not
predictable at the same time sometimes i
will go into iop and i'll think i know
where key's going and the king starts
talking like oh god okay we're on the
same side i didn't know this okay let me
let me
re-re-evaluate what i was going to say
how could i disagree hmm
i mean look i'll just say this i i saw
slo-mo playing it and you slow-mo you
know shout out to snowmobile backslap if
y'all aren't subscribed to him that make
sure y'all subscribe to my man channel
he for his 1000 subscribers special he
actually had to play that game um
another friend of the show jack moved
johnny he played that game and i think
he stopped i didn't think he finished
that game i think there was a part where
he couldn't like finish it and um all
the marketing led me to believe that if
you didn't have a ps5 you couldn't play
that game at all so
i mean you know it's cool it's coming to
xbox i hope y'all actually play you king
and enjoy it you know cause i think i
think you'll like it plus i hear the
story is pretty deep now i won't be
playing it because i'm i'm cool on that
i had a ps4 the whole time i i i ain't
thinking about no damn bugs next man um
godfather either i ain't thinking about
no golf i leave it and there was another
game that was on our playstation um
attic you remember day one um
it was the racing game they thought it
was like burning destruction all-stars
i see people saying to get king on here
king is a busy person okay usually i
have to give a king i have to give king
like a day or two
in advance to come on here because he's
always running around doing stuff i
might try to have king on the next
couple weeks i already have the guests
for next week lined up so maybe we'll
try to get king on the week after that
and plus next week we're going to packs
as well so i'm not trying to overlord
the lords and anything you're not doing
the show next week all we have to do if
you're going to packs uh no we're doing
a show it's a wednesday pax i get home
on a mo on a sunday
all right cool you got it
all right i know what password i thought
passing through yeah
um 22nd
i think no way i leave wednesday no we
won't have a show next week i leave
wednesday morning
yeah because then yeah
next week unless you want to do a
tuesday
it's up to you i mean i wouldn't want to
hold you up if you got a pack and all
that just let me know ain't no big deal
yeah we'll do it tuesday we'll do it
tuesday all right okay what are they
gonna call the the pax flu this time
usually uh friends of mine whenever they
go to pax like everybody gets sick
they're like
i actually don't get sick after events
really
this isn't what but i'm knocking on it
okay don't get me sick next week sorry
there you go he's got it all right so
let me ask you guys a question before we
move on all right when it comes to
game pass i'm gonna ask you guys two
games
that you would like to see on game pass
it doesn't have to be it could be as
long as it's realistic don't give me
some god award don't give me nothing
like that two games that you
realistically and realistic you could
stretch that like if you want a game
that's exclusive that's a multi-player
on another platform i'll give you that
you know what i'm saying so tell me what
you guys would want to see on game pass
you go first also
oh put me right on the spot okay fine
i'll go i got it in my head all right so
any of the lego games just because um as
a parent
i think
game pass needs more kids games man i
love the lego games and it really does
like they got developer outright games
has been put a couple games on there and
i think
they need to uh they need to find some
more kids games on there and then
another another series is
jesus you see i've only got the one it's
just the lego games well any the ubisoft
games are common right so it's like
those games too like any of those big
third-party um
aaa experiences
those are what like game pass would eat
it up any gamer i can go in there and
play forever i don't want the rockstar
games i get it they go on and on they go
on and off but
i'm i'm looking more like give me give
me uh give me assassin's creed or you
know what assassin's creed is probably
too much give me the next watch dogs
it's not the biggest ubisoft property
but you can go in there you can eat it
up you can play it for a couple days and
then you can hop out of it um okay and
um is it sikhi or
cikr he took my ass or she took my ass
or whoever that was they're in the chat
you don't have to talk about the chat
keep going yeah yeah stay in the chat
well no no i'm acknowledging my
knowledge no you can acknowledge them
but you don't have to like they took my
answer you in the show not then what's
your answer this is
that's how you do this they took your
answer not the other way around
well i ain't into robbing our people but
no thank you for typing in the chat but
no persona would be like
the first one all the personas would be
like ideal like for game pass um
we haven't seen final fantasy 7 yet
either attic in there the remake i mean
we haven't seen that yet so like that's
that's another like good one that
probably should be there
uh for me i mean if i had to pick
something ideally it would be third
party it'll be mad it'll be what's the
best way to try to get everybody so you
want to gain date right this madden is
there but it's just not yeah but it'll
have to be there they want like what's
the best way to get a lot of people over
because they already look like they're
about to buy call of duty from what we
can tell so
no i just i i would say persona for sure
um let's see what else i'm not gonna say
spiderman i saw king say spiderman in
the chat i'm not gonna say spiderman and
spider on miles morale
hey listen miles morales is a fire game
i don't know if y'all haven't played
that yet please do yourself a favor that
that that honestly incredible miles
morales is one of the best christmas
games that we've seen on a call i
actually think miles is better than the
original spider-man yeah
once again i have memories of playing my
daughter this christmas wanted to play
it again because you can go around at
christmas time and it's snowing and she
can swing around with spider-man and she
loves using the costume with the kitty
cat on the back yeah yeah
and she'll do that all day long and then
she goes to like the yeah
all the other different places whenever
bad guys come she just hands me the
controller she's like all right there
you go it's your turn
yeah now i had uh i like the probably
giving for myself uh at that joint was
the purple and one of my favorite colors
was purple but like that that was it for
me um
as far as any other games uh i don't
really think
i don't really think game pass is really
missing much i don't think persona is
that really big one though that's the
one that everybody's scared of like i
anticipate all right so
my two are gonna be on that borderline
between realistic and not realistic i
feel like microsoft has done a really
good job trying to appeal more to a
japanese audience like people love that
genre not necessarily a japanese
audience but people that like that
but i feel like
they need
to start hitting that with day and date
games
uh you know
that's why i feel like if they went out
there and they was able to not only
negotiate pacerno persona 6 coming the
game
to xbox but it'd also be game pass day
and date and then they were able to
negotiate sure you can't get final
fantasy
but that kingdom hearts 4 coming at game
pass day and date i feel like if they
were to negotiate that they would shut
me up i couldn't make videos about how
they ain't trying like like to me i
think the the the absolute highest thing
which we can move on to this because
it's been a huge topic is xbox with
japanese games you know miles shout out
to him he made an article about it
talking about that microsoft needs to do
a better job of getting these games you
know like triangle strategy nintendo
exclusive sure that's not on playstation
but it's not on xbox either you got
final fantasy we've got two iterations
of that not on the the platform you know
and i feel like when it comes to these
type of games
people always tell me attic the reason
people aren't doing it is because people
aren't buying it straight up cat
if you don't give us the best ones of
these we're not going to experiment in
the genre itself you have to give us the
key components to this genre the final
fantasy the personas the dragon quest
they did a good job with dragon quest
11. not going to take that away from
them but you got to do more you got to
put the pedal to the metal and that's
why i feel like if you put kingdom
hearts 4
and persona 6 especially persona 6. if
persona 6 not only came to xbox but it
was on game pass day and date you would
sell consoles you realize how crazy that
would be
um
they sell consoles like 100 like they
were i was i can't remember i think it
was windows central did an article on
they were talking about how
if you go into those western stores um
they don't even offer game pass like you
walk i mean xbox you just walk in they
sell them there but they don't even
offer them to you you walk in it's just
a playstation or a nintendo when you go
into those stores or um
across the water there and
that's also their biggest problem but
the xbox series s is actually doing well
in asian marketplaces so this is the
time i think you're right that's yeah
it's the better answer it's it's the hey
here's how you grow if you want to grow
xbox and grow game pass you need that
other audience you have north america
you need the rest and you know we're
about to talk about xbox selling uh
consoles and units uh so you know let's
go to move on to that you know since you
opened up that uh that worm hole uh
we've been seeing you know me and hustle
talked about a couple weeks ago where
they won well a week or two but it's
looking like here consistently they're
actually selling really well like the
series x and the s not sure you can go
on there you could talk about how many
units this person could make having to
use that first command that's all cute
that doesn't mean nothing at the end of
the day what means something is what
they're selling now because if anyone
knows anything
the people who sell the most consoles in
the first couple years they generally do
extremely well if not win the generation
the rest of the year because
what you're seeing now is you're seeing
a lot of people buying the xbox and i
and people are like well you know when
when the uh xbox when these these chips
and stuff come up
you're not to see that addict because
you're going to see if you can go into
any play any place and buy playstation 5
that's what people are going to do but
here's the thing
playstation isn't doing bad
but
this is a platform that was dominant
last generation
to me
if x like i i thought xbox would do well
but i didn't expect this i really did i
expected xbox series x's to be on the
shelves for a couple weeks they slowly
go off but not to be they aren't off on
off sure there's s's everywhere but i'm
pretty sure s's are easier to make than
series x's 100
and what's funny is people sit there and
say
oh go ahead and speak no no no i got
something that that goes against that
too addict um i went to best buy
yesterday whenever monday was when i won
the best by monday um i actually had to
go pick up my elgato ring light and um
they don't sell at best buy they don't
sell the xbox series s's online because
everybody was bought and using the box
to get them and everything so there's
that well at least
let the local one in my area they ain't
got no game stops though then the game
stop i went to today that's not there
and it's not uh another gamestop that
are frequent as well so the the series
x's the ps5 and stuff they're not there
the series s's are though
yeah well the the s's were for me as
well um but just recently i was just in
the local walmart the other day and they
didn't have any for the first time in a
little bit like usually but i could
still go online right now i bet you if i
go on amazon right now i bet you i could
buy one right now i had one i uh
upgraded i have to
well i'm gonna sound very i'm gonna
sound lucky here but i have two x's oh
well look lucky you yeah well i traded
what i did was i traded i had an s and i
traded and then i'd already had a it
doesn't matter i ended up getting two
x's it just it works out but i guarantee
if i go on yes the series s's but i have
a funny that i think that was xbox's
whole idea the whole time like they
couldn't foresee the shortage coming but
yeah you're gonna buy one on amazon
right now a year ago
phil spencer did say
that right now
i don't know if it's changed but he did
say that they were focusing more
because regardless if certain components
aren't there for an xbox series snx
we'll have to get someone on here that
knows tech like that i would assume
there are certain variables that both of
them have you know what i'm saying i
don't know how what they are but uh you
know he did say that they were
prioritizing the series x like like six
months to a year ago i don't know if
they've changed that up
but you know what's funny is like you
have
you know you have um people that you
know they it's crazy that like people
will dismiss the series that's including
myself
you know i'm not the biggest series s
fan because i had like bad i have like
bad flashbacks with the xbox one and the
xbox one x moments uh you know i stayed
multiple times me and kid smooth playing
gears and him loading up way faster on
the
gears on his x than i was on the series
on the xbox one x so what's funny about
that is
they learned then
that
these multi consoles as long as you
promote them correctly they work
and that's why i feel like in certain
aspects they had to make sure certain
things in both consoles were the same to
make sure that they were able to get the
same
type of not maybe not necessarily in
terms of you know quality but they can
get a lot of the same games to run
identical maybe not like
visually wise but performance wise you
know what i'm saying like and you know
obviously we have certain devs that hit
like 30 frames on the series s every now
and then and i think that's to be given
because i do think that it does take a
little bit more to get to that series s
the way the x does and that's subjective
and all that but what's interesting
about this is just like i said like xbox
was not doing the greatest last
generation and if you would feel like if
you would go into the beginning of the
generation you would ask me addict
what do you think the series s and the
series actually gonna do i would say
look i think they're you know they're
gonna do well but i always thought that
series s and x would start picking up
when their games started picking up
but it doesn't seem like that's the case
like they're
if you think about it they sold
games in a month where they had not only
did they not have anything coming out
because i think we can all agree that
the past couple months you know besides
like a game pass perspective they've had
kind of a weak month
uh they're still outselling the
competition
with them launching their games
so it's like to me it's like if you're
out selling your competition
during the months that they have these
games coming out and i get it
the ps5 and the ps5 digital
they're you know they they're a little
bit harder to come out out the gate but
to me that's that's subjective that
doesn't even matter
because
what's going on now is you're seeing the
beginning of the generation and i
honestly feel like by the time stuff
comes out and by the time like these
chips start coming out very frequently
we're going to ask court here in a
minute
at that point
your friends are going to have a series
s and x
your your brothers and sisters gonna
have a series s and x your parents are
gonna have a series s and x and you're
gonna naturally and i'm not saying like
my parents but obviously there's a lot
of parents that game and you're gonna
naturally gravitate towards where they
are
so it's like just because they kind of
like playstation and sony have like a
little bit of a hiccup right now i do
feel like them not trying to take the
initiative because there was a lot of
rumors going around that microsoft uh
did the uh they prioritized their own
their own stock over everyone else and i
think the reason they did that is
because they know that the longer the
generation goes
that's when it start that's when the
domino effect happens i buy a system
let's say kid smooth haven't bought a
system yet he's going to naturally buy a
system because that's where i'm playing
and you're going to see that domino
effect from here on out so what do you
feel about that court do you do you feel
like i'm bugging
no i i also think
from a personal standpoint i know of
many people that had a playstation 5 but
because there was even with horizon this
is before horizon when the hype train
happened with forza
and
halo from that november december that's
a lot of times where people are itching
to spend money well those xbox series
s's were available to buy i know so many
people that bought one then
and then liked the console so much that
when the x dropped bought an x just in
the last six months so you're getting
not only are you getting the people that
already wanted an xbox so you can get
one so the xbox is more available you
have game pass which is a hype machine
by itself then you even have the people
that had a ps5 that they're like you
know what people haven't been able to
leave their houses for two years not
going on vacations they have a little
bit extra kind of cash they go out and
buy a second console like last gen i had
a ps5 and an xbox one but i barely
turned on that xbox one that thing was
it might as well have been a vcr it may
look like one but it might as well been
one because it just didn't get used
i was using my ps4
now you have the ps5 and the xbox series
people are using both consoles for this
is the first generation i would say more
people are using dual consoles than ever
and you're seeing people that have like
i said they bought the s and then they
upgrade to the x because like i was
finding issues with my s when i was
using him one of my issues was when i
was playing backwards compact games and
i'll use batman arkham as an example
the game had some frame rate issues hard
on the s because it was trying to push
all these extra extra
screens i was getting screen tears on
the ass but i know on my axe i would go
downstairs into my basement and play it
on my axe i'm like oh my god it's the s
it's because the hdr auto updates and
all that that was made for the x so i
was having issues with my x and it was
driving me at s and it was driving me
nuts so in my office area i was like i
want to upgrade i couldn't get an x a
friend of mine bought an x he was like i
don't he's like i actually wanted the s
i was like well i'll just pay the
difference and we switched
so
i think this is the first generation
where you're getting more people that
are buying more consoles and i would be
almost safe to say even those people
that you see online those those sony
people call them sony ponies whatever
they want to be called they people just
pick a side i guarantee they still have
an xbox probably
yeah oh for sure
you want to be part of that zeitgeist
you want part of the conversation i mean
if they if they're like me typically
what i do
every generation since the ps3 as a
matter of fact i pretty much get all
three consoles nintendo xbox and
playstation i typically get all three
and um like i said when i went to best
buy on monday the fact that um
i went over there and i saw so many xbox
series x's there and the girl shout out
to well shout out to ann she know her
name well she knows she is but she told
me she was like she's like yeah you can
come back like next week them consoles
not gonna be gone because they were
sitting there for a while they just
don't have them online but um no that's
that's that's like super dope to me um
like i said i like physical games the s
wouldn't suit me at all that'd be like a
big waste of money and i got a nice pc
down here already so that'd be a big
waste of money to me i want something
that i can just like pop a disc in and
you know and get to it no matter you
know if it's on the og xbox
um but you know grand theft auto uh san
andreas that works on like your xbox if
you have xbox one x i didn't notice but
that works on it it gives you the 720p
version but that still works on it and i
can only imagine this is going to work
on the x as well i got the backup behind
me i got the 360 the sds and then the
playstation one back there so i'll i'll
i can play some old backwards compat but
i'm with you on that one yeah and that's
the other thing too um another reason
why well for me another reason why like
i really want the ps5 digital or
physical rather
but so i can play all up back in times
like what's up
someone's i'm sorry okay so so what's
this sounds like the series s is the
gateway
it is though it might
the amount of people i know that bought
that console and now upgraded to an x
when that new stock came out is
astounding to me
um i mean but
certainly
we got this job for you man
you know you it will open up your eyes
open up your mind
i think it was battlefield that didn't
run so hard on the s uh battlefield 2042
that that didn't run so hard on the s i
don't think that ran hard on anything
yeah well yeah you know what that's
that right
yeah that's right
oh man well hey i'm not going i'm like
i'm like on criticizing because i
haven't played it but um one of the
people close to me uh they did play and
they was like yo it just it just said
this didn't run well and you know but it
probably wasn't the finance of the game
yeah i i don't even blame the developers
when a company like ea is in control
they decide when games come out and ea's
done it way too many times where they
put out a broken game and they're like
well people pay for it and if you saw
what they said after the fact they were
like you knew it was broken we just
figured we could fix it down the line
you just keep giving us money
i know what to say on topic but i kind
of couldn't believe that they tried to
blame halo for the uh oh my god
that was alert don't say that man i got
jumped on by the whole community they
didn't say that i'm like no you don't
bring up another company unless you have
unless you low-key have some kind of
resentment i'm not saying they hate 343
or halo but they did in some way feel
like they took away from their shine
guess what you took away from your own
shot and had nothing to do with three
fourth thing hey that's wild uh like
you'd have thought they you know i was
gonna say you thought there was a
youtuber but yeah because oh boy that
that's wild that's why i don't think
that a company would do that but um
it is what it is um
you know for for me again like the fact
that i can just pop in like ninja gaiden
and it does like the you know how xbox
the the the whole hold on if i if i put
a og xbox game in there right
will it upscale it like it does in game
pass because it kind of reworked
everything and then put it up to 1080p
so
was the reason why i wanted to switch so
i have uh an x downstairs on the tv and
that's what i use for the family and
then i was upstairs in my office and a
friend of mine gave me a stack of 360
games arkham origins gave me all these
games and so like i'm i'm i'm like oh i
can't i don't have the digital copy so
then i pop them in on my xbox series x
and i'm like hold on a second
i'm like did they do this glow up or
whatever and i look it up and it's just
like no just auto hdr the games look
different like arkham origins looks
beautiful
assassin's creed one
runs 60 frames per second and looks
crazy pants
on the xbox series x it's just it
astounds me how good old games and i'm i
i have no problem playing old games i i
thoroughly enjoy it um i just
it's just something i do and i'm like
wow the x is just that thing it's just a
gift it keeps on giving sometimes
indeed indeed
before we go on any further hey um
tonight at 8 pm eastern standard time
y'all go ahead and go to level one
gamers channel they have the double xp
podcast tonight with special guest
khalif adams i do believe oakland that's
not enough i'll be interested but i want
you to guess sir yes sir
my family y'all put put the link in the
chat
uh hey hey y'all mods in here level one
put your link in the chat
see he's like he like you doing the
right work i ain't doing
all right so you know obviously when it
comes to the let me get my bars off a
little bit when it comes to this
uh like i said i'm kind of
surprised that it happened i'm not
shocked
because i do feel like people try to
undervalue
what game pass is doing for the platform
i've said multiple times on this
platform
that
people they take exclusivity when they
buy stuff they take where their friends
when they buy something they take all
these matters and all these factors into
account when they buy something
but you know what the number one thing
people take encounter when they buy
something value
and that value of game password you
could go in and you could buy a series s
or an xbox series x and you could walk
out with 200 plus games in some matters
i don't know what's on there now they're
always putting stuff on putting stuff
off putting stuff on but when you have
this
amount of value that you could leave
with that type of games and we're not
talking like sure some of the games on
there might not appeal to you you might
think some of the games are too
kiddie-ish for you in terms of how they
look
kind of like everyone thinks fortnite
looks kitty fortnite's one of the
biggest games in the world the biggest
games in the gaming industry
just because you don't like something
doesn't mean the masses don't
uh you know you might think you if
you're a racer on there you know if you
like rts's and you have a pc you could
play
stuff on there like people
need to put more respect
on that game pass
that's that's besides the fact i do feel
like
sony's got a little bit of a breathing
room because i do feel
truly feel
that these numbers are going to be very
different when you see fable start
coming out perfect darts start coming
out of vows start coming out
all these games that they've been
working on
starcraft
is successful that's starcraft story uh
jesus why am i my brain not working
what's the game that's coming out in
november why why is garfield star fields
yeah it's that's the uh that's the uh
maybe covet brain but um
that game
could make or break game pass like the
system is a very important thing
because
it's very very important to xbox this
game
i think it's important but i would say
that like ninja theories game is it i
would say starfield's important for this
year but i feel like hellblade
avowed
uh stated k3
and those are probably the biggest three
the reason i feel like those are more
important overall is because those show
because star all star fields going to do
is show microsoft spent money to get an
exclusive game the weapon if the game's
bad like let's be real here no no there
is definitely a realm where this is this
ends bad but all i'm saying is like when
it comes to hellblade state of the k3
in a vowed those games are going to show
what microsoft can do
before a game comes out you know i guess
when it comes like the outer worlds by
the time they came out it was already
done starfield already done but whatever
if they if they
like i still say right now halo infinite
is not a finished game it is the
campaign it's not finished the
multiplayer is not finished that game
i loved my time with it but it was way
too many times i was playing that
campaign and i was lucky enough thank
you xbox canada getting to play that
game early the amount of times that i
got to like a certain point i'm like oh
there's a door here well that door
doesn't open and then you find out from
the developers 40 of the game they just
put to the other side
i wish they would have just let me
finish that game and i'm hoping
starfield isn't that where it's a halo
drop it's great for a little bit and it
loses its shine
i was seeing that
some of the weird stuff unique stuff
that that developers do like i was
seeing on on on youtube when when the
kingdom hearts developers wanted to make
reflections you know how they did that
they would have it to where a puddle
would have like a surface top where you
couldn't go into it but it would just be
if you looked into the puddle you would
see the reflection right but all that
really is
is the game upside down
under it
so i was like that that's unique man
that's unique look all i'm saying is i
definitely understand where you're
coming from court like as far as i do
think that that's going to represent how
bethesda is now obviously they're
together
that's going i think star field is going
to determine how
well elder scrolls 6 does
because if if starfield comes out and
it's not the greatest elder scrolls 6 is
still going to do well but if starfield
comes out hits it out of the park elder
scrolls will probably do
way more just off yeah but if starfield
comes out and does hits it out of the
park
your game like because the game's coming
out right around the holiday season
that will be the number one thing people
are going to want is game pass or that
console if they don't have it
mm-hmm
and just to play that game
right now we're talking about star field
wait till we start having conversations
with charlotte was
we're talking about star field right now
wait till we start having this this
conversation with elder scrolls
yeah fairly true that's so sick 20 22
million copies
across
what was the final i'm gonna look that
up i saw it one time and i was in shock
people don't realize how popular elder
scrolls is
and when that hits that obviously we
know that that's an exclusive because
they they've talked about it being an
exclusive 30 million
copies but when that game officially
launches court and hustle
and it's and it's an exclusive it's
going to hit different
and that's why i feel like the outer
worlds 2 that was the other game out of
worlds too
so good yeah out of words to avowed
hellblade 2
and stated k3 and the reason i feel like
those are very important games for
microsoft is because it shows that they
bought a studio and they improved it
like they we all look for these four
games to be improved from their
predecessors because most of these games
came out
they were already done or already
released
so my question for you and both of you
you we've all played them we all played
follow we've all played these games
are we gonna be okay if they're broken
like they because back in the day when
the follow-up follow-up fallout came out
it was okay that it was broken right
we're like oh it's bethesda that's
that's what they do right are we okay if
they're broken they
they need to come out
like there's a difference between broken
and glitches
like there's a couple of glitches
there's the brokens okay well
here's the thing
besides fallout 76 they've had serious
issues on certain platforms
but
i have always said when it comes to
these giant rpgs is your fun factor
has to almost be double what the bugs
are
as long as they can keep that up i think
they'll be fine and as long as there's
no game breaking glitches as long as
there's no game breaking glitches and
you're having double the fun that you're
being annoyed throughout the game
they'll be fine what do you think hustle
well first of all courtney
rebound off of what you said this is the
game that i die for
that i die for no this game can't come
out broken first and foremost and you
know why i can't
that acquisition that money taught baby
that eight point was it 7.4 billion
money tough like you you got way too
much money now to even allow something
like that and i think todd howard and
the team epithelia i think they know
that now so now this drink can't come
out with the normal bug that's the games
like this is why we stayed away from
them joints this is why that's a t-shirt
that is a t-shirt has that amen look
they should make that t-shirt they
really shouldn't have beat that t-shirt
they they should have they're supposed
to cash out but you know what i'll work
in their marketing department they don't
want no money but no no but but the
money like the
the budget that they have now i mean you
only have to assume that it's higher
because it's microsoft and here's the
thing microsoft know that too they know
that um
they know that uh starfield is gonna be
like the
big seller they know it's gonna be like
the big seller that month because they
announced the date a whole year before
the joint drops so they they know like
there are a year and a half before drop
they already know we'll see some stuff
at e3 well not e3 let's see some stuff
whatever microsoft is doing around the
e3 time we'll see something else we'll
probably see some gameplay and then you
know you know bethesda yeah but if you
look bethesda normally doesn't show
their game until seven or six months
before their game releases yeah and i
think they'll show something and they
drop i like that about bethesda though
june
we'll get it in june i think we'll get
it in june i think the reason that they
kind of like like look but doesn't
usually rose one certain way but they
changed it up a little bit because that
was when fallout 76 happened i felt like
they wanted to give
a lot of
what's what i'm looking for a lot of
hope back into the bethesda fans that's
why they announced starfield way before
it came out and that's why they
announced elder scrolls six
if if fallout 76 and they knew they were
positive that game was going to do well
i don't think they would announce follow
uh
starfield and elder scrolls i think it
would have been one of those games that
you know they push on but you know let's
go ahead and uh push on from that
subject it was a nice little step to
talk about
certain infiniti i'm sure a lot of you
in the chat know with the studios and
i'm sure courtney hussell knows this the
studio's been helping
343 with halo for a long time now
and now it's officially looking like
they've actually merged not necessarily
merged but they're pretty much
permanently contracting them for the
foreseeable future to make
halo content now right now it's rumored
that they're making some kind of game
mode uh regardless if it's a battle
royale or a different type of mode or
maybe like a battlefield mode i would be
actually more interested in a
battlefield mode like it sounds like the
rumor it's
that's what it sounds like it's like a
it's more but it's like more if they
called like the lone wolf or last man
standing type thing like it's gonna be
it sounds like a battle royale i've
always felt like battle royale works
well in the halo universe i think it
would withdraw those maps it's like i've
said multiple times man just imagine
being uh like you're dropping down in
odsd pods
and the map pops up at first
shows all the locations you click where
you want to go and the odsd pawn just
drops you straight down
it's made for that wow that sounds
fantastic like you're just sitting there
you're like playing and also this pod
just crashes beside you and like knocks
your player over so you can't shoot the
guy right away oh
and like
do you think they i feel like you need
to start off a pistol if this happens
you need 100 pistols
maybe do stuff different though like
that's what i like about apex legends is
they took that formula and they made it
their own they made it throw on so much
that the people who made that formula
low key stole they stuff so
like because originally you couldn't you
couldn't um you couldn't mark stuff on
that map on fortnight couldn't revive
each other unfortunately
but yeah the ping system but when when
apex legends showed up and they
innovated that genre they made it unique
to themselves fortnite came in the back
door was like we like this we like this
we like this and they implemented those
into their game i want that with halo if
i don't care like i'm not the other
people people feel like they don't need
to do it at all
i don't think they need it but i do
think it would help
it's just like look like imagine going
to halo infinite
battle royale on the left area on the
right customs on the bottom like that's
what they need sure you're going to
split your your fan base but
the people that's going to play arena
right now 9 times out of ten they're not
playing a battle royale you need to
bring a fan base back yeah i feel like i
fell off the game for god's sakes and i
do an xbox show yeah i feel like their
biggest thing now is to not only bring
those people back
but
give it that mode that is streamable
give it that mode that people will
stream constantly that people will play
constantly give it that mode that's
popular arena is fun but it's not
popular let's be real here arena wasn't
what it was 10 years ago 15 years ago
i get it people don't like the battle
royale because of fortnite because of
apex legends but at the end of the day
that is what's popping right now and i
don't see that going away anytime soon
the battle royale structure is so
streamable it's not even funny you start
every game fresh
and you fight your way up to that last
three or four ma people fighting
halo needs that
i don't think
i don't think that they desperately need
it to keep alive i think that could be
fine just releasing content but if they
want to be mainstream and competing with
these people every year they're going to
need it
and you know it's like i said do the
odsd drops man have draw like have
multiple ways over stuff but have kill
zone boxes to where you can
uh what's what's this thing uh the
energy
uh
bridges that they put in halo light
bridges yeah the light bridges have it
where you could put those on and off and
people can can lock down areas but
there's always another way around like
and then like not to mention if you
don't have a light bridge take a pelican
over there
take a hornet over there like there's
other ways that they can do it that
makes sense to the halo brand and that's
all i ask certain infiniti if you are
doing a halo battle royale make it your
own and don't just copy off people
hmm
would you like to go before me no i'm
gonna let you go
okay well i'm gonna be the contrarian
here like i don't give a damn who they
get it's over it's a wrap that joint
started off with a quarter million
people playing it
it's over it's more people playing
master chief collection right now on pc
huh
no i was just fixing my camera oh okay
no there's more people playing massive
chief collection right now on pc than it
is halo um infinite man what you saying
wait what what's this because there's
more content on the master chief
collection yeah because they released a
game that wasn't finished yeah but and
you know and i'm glad they didn't
release it on the original release date
because lord knows what we would have
gotten now um before people like jump
off the deep in there me i got 40 hours
in the game you know i think i got to
like level
40 or something like that during that
battle pass whatever i had fun they get
the game is fun they just need more
modes so with the new mode aside from
this uh rumored uh battle royale mode
they said king of the hell is coming
back oh my listen um ign unlocked they
had um adam cole on there and they was
like you know some of the modes that
they like king of the hill is probably
one of my favorite modes especially when
it comes to halo um because that's
actually what i'm used to it's not like
gears the way you you know jump in a
circle and you lock it down and then let
your points keep going up until somebody
break the circle
now with halo you got to stay in that
you got to stay within the
hill he'll move hill control y'all know
what i'm talking about you got to stay
there so like this more game modes and
like for me i'll jump back into it but
it's not going i don't think it's going
to hit those numbers for quite some time
but i have a way that um they can
actually come back
um i'll call it the cs uh sea of thieves
syndrome um they can get like summit or
whoever's big and like the you know fps
community to like actually start playing
halo again and start playing a little
online because it is free
and yeah and they can be back
when something like that happens they
maybe they get dr disrespect in the tab
man maybe they
slide him a couple dollars you know hey
don't play it for a little bit and
i'm all about buying if you can buy
these people to play your game do it
like people don't realize that
that's just a form of marketing people
want to sit there and try to look down
on that paying streamers to play games
that's a form of marketing do you think
that when you see these giant um you
know actresses and these hollywood
influencers on these commercials you
think they're doing that at the kindness
of their heart no they're getting money
to do it
we got a two dollar strip trap from
hustle uh from not for me except for
flame hustle is right scrap halo
infinite hush you're so we're nice
well that's what i'm saying i i think i
think i i agree a little bit like i
think they had they had they had this
thing they had 25 million people they
had a game where you know
the halo before was meh some people
liked it some people didn't they had
this audience they had the hype they had
all this momentum and a lot of it had to
do with game pass was doing well xbox
was just knocking out of the park forza
hit and everybody was like oh my god
xbox is back xbox is real the hype
machine behind xbox was at its apex for
the first time in forever and then they
released halo infinite and it was like
you'd see some people it was almost like
people were giving it a review based on
being halo like i was on a show and i
before we started they're like what's
your score going to be i'm like well
it's 7.5 and they're like what this
game's amazing i'm like is it though i'm
like what what what part about it is
amazing they're like well this and i'm
like but is it amazing like is it what
you wanted it to be or is this a game
that could have released on previous gen
and been the same like are are we
getting anything different what are they
they have this giant expansive map but
there's nothing to do on it and then
they brought out a multiplayer that yes
it's for free but still technically it's
coming with the game is it free i don't
know what's on game pass but at the same
time i'm like the core gameplay in halo
infinite multiplayer is amazing
but there's nothing to do
you you got no one wants to play it with
you and they decided they're like hey
we're going to try something different
and we're going to here's our we're not
going to give you xp drip like i'm
having a lot of time a lot of fun with
mlb the show because it gives me xp no
matter what i do play exhibition game
doesn't matter i'm getting xp towards
their battle pass because everything has
a battle pack because yeah
you can't go 18 and one and only get 200
xp in a match it's embarrassing
because what it does is it makes it feel
like what you're doing
look
i've always been one of those people
where like we need to go away from the
kd ratio but you still need to have
mechanics
and
and gameplay features that's in place to
reward you for doing good
uh you know there's a reason when you're
playing battlefield when you heal
someone court what do you get
would you know when you revive someone
in battlefield what do you get you get
points yes when you kill you get what
you get you get points you're getting
rewarded for doing things
halo doesn't reward you for playing the
game when you play a game that's
supposed to be an online multiplayer
like even battlefields broken game still
rewards you for trying to play it
you're still getting something there
it's kind of sad that it's a reward
system is better than halo's reward
system and how bad that game came out
let me
let me get these super chats before they
get too crazy we got five dollars can
you guys hear me fine yeah i switched my
mic in case you ain't noticed we got a
five dollar super chat from donald taco
sea of thieves and no man's sky had had
far less players in the first year and
both games are thriving now halo will be
fine once it gets content that's where i
was gonna bring up here in a minute
let's talk about that here um if anyone
can bounce back
from no man's sky
uh if if they can bounce back from that
any studio can bounce back sure i will
say that there was extremely extreme
circumstances that led to them going the
way they did
but
they still are able to bounce back if
they if that small studio like that can
bounce back a corporation such as xbox
can easily do it it's just can they do
it right and then you got to look at it
from no man's sky
that studio i can't remember what
they're called
something i don't know do you guys
remember what that studio is called
games
what i don't know we'll call it sean
murray is the uh yeah so
see the thing is when it comes to sean
murray
is he decides everything
if they have a vision for no man's sky
hello i thought it was called halo games
if halo games has a vision for no man's
sky
the only people they have to convince is
sean murray
when halo needs a vision for no man's
sky they got to go through xbox they got
to go through the higher ups there then
they xbox got to get approved through
microsoft because they fund everything
there's a little bit difference between
the two but i understand where you're
coming from donald tucker we got a two
dollar super chat 279 super chat from
rdx son of fete
just says there's still another halo
game it's going to be interesting um
i do agree with you donna taku like see
these and no man's sky uh especially sea
of thieves sea of thieves was kind of
like
i honestly thought it was gonna be a
dead man game at first but they they
came out and they proved me wrong they
proved me wrong so much that the the
millions millions thing was a joke me
saying that there's not a millions of
people playing it and i still think i
was right at that time there was
definitely not millions of people
playing seed thieves and there's
probably not millions of people playing
seed thieves now but there has been
millions of people to play sea of
thieves
i loved jumping into cfds and i truly
think if halo even a year from now
because it's they're lucky it's on game
pass right so if there's ever new stuff
and halo is big again you got an xbox
but you know so many people bought one
you could just re-download the game i i
deleted the game it is not even on my
console anymore because i am just not
there's nothing for me there's no drip
there's just nothing there
but if they decide to do a huge
expansion and rework the the single
player and be like hey here's co-op but
here's like
10 hours more of content and here's
10 new maps
on multiplayer and because they've
already said they are going to be giving
xp for uh you know just killing somebody
or playing the actual game you're going
to get xp for actually do it they said
all that's coming back they bring all
that back and actually give content and
be like a re-launch of the game i think
they'll get everybody back it's halo and
i think they're they'll need
i don't think it's season two
but i think they're gonna need
a j like a sizable story expansion along
with it to get people because i feel
like if you give people
a good amount of story content you're
going to get people to come back to play
that story content and i feel like those
same people will try the multiplayer
again since they're playing the game
and if you can captivate them in those
first couple games when they come back
you know imagine like you you you're
getting a double kill it just shows like
points going on double kill triple kill
you're kill tacular you just see points
going up over and over again you're
feeling like being rewarded those people
probably gonna stay around for a couple
games
sorry yeah i was saying then you know
then you'll have people come and play
other games oh man like oh kid you they
they fix that thing before you know i'm
jumping on and playing playing with
smooth hustle's playing with me and then
you get this giant cycle going on and
everyone's playing halo again
yeah but like they could even do like
that that's like giving me an epiphany
like
they could do that whole like i don't
know if anybody's ever because i'm old
rainbow six vegas two way back in the
day they had the multiplayer component
and they had the single player when you
played the single player you earn xp
went to both single player and
multiplayer
god forbid when halo brings in their
co-op the things you do and the leveling
up system that you do in the single
player you can use it you get rewarded
for playing the game not just
the multiplayer you get rewarded for
playing the game that's what people want
we we look at this way everybody always
says game pass is free it ain't free
you're paying it here in canada 380 for
the year 10 to 15 minutes of the year
it's not cheap so if you reward people's
time because we've learned something
over the last two years our time is
important um
and the people around us are important
so we've learned to do other things so
if you reward people for their time
they're gonna stick with your game this
is the way it is that's the way it works
now that's why people play fortnite
because they're rewarded for it they go
in there they end up getting skins
they're working towards something that's
the reason so many people play destiny
yeah what what are you and everybody's
loving destiny destiny brought out that
new expansion all i hear is amazing
things about destiny right now so
you're getting those people that play
the game and go into it they're getting
rewards but when those rewards go away
why do i need to play your game anymore
you're not giving me anything you you
want me to play it for no reason
i'll say um if halo wants me to come
back
uh that co-op needs to be there man um
it'll be there and i'm disappointed with
them that they didn't this season not
next season though
i think i don't think nothing comes this
season just season two well hold on i
mean season two i mean i meant it won't
be coming back in season two we probably
won't see that during until like
september sometime man but
that that's actually what i'm waiting on
that's that's that's what i'm waiting on
sure if king of the hill comes back sure
but
i'll actually like buy the game when the
when the co-op is there because i got a
couple of people who are running with
and make sure it's full player co-op and
just make sure it runs right online
which
i'm sure i have no doubt in my mind that
it will but i just hope that it i hope
that that part of it is flawless um
i said earlier that they can't recover
and i feel like from the multiplayer
standpoint
right now i kind of feel like they came
with what they're offering i wanted to
make sure i you know i didn't forget
anything but
that
that that battle royale mode if it is
true that that's gonna have to hit for
something
that's going to they're for something
crazy that means it's gonna have to be
like the next big thing
that's what i'm saying that's what i'm
saying like this one had to be the next
big i just think in terms of beyond me
the way i would in a perfect world what
i wanted to do is i'd want them to make
to make their map
like
uh what was the uh the call of duty one
before war zone blackout was isn't that
what that was called
black ops i think black ops no it was
the it was the
the battle royale before war zone that
call of duty made i think it was
blackout
oh i think you're right i think you're
right uh you know how like in blackout i
don't know what they do in warzone but
blackout them the parts on the map were
multiplayer maps of the game
and i felt like that if they could do
that
in halo
i feel like that would hit more because
people remember what guardian looks like
people remember what haven from blackout
uh from halo 4 are people remember those
maps they love those maps so if they're
able to do that i think that would be
cool where you could just like let's
drop let's drop in guardian you know
what i'm saying like
i think that would hit very well but it
just depends on how they do it that's
the key point
they could do this time next year we
could be having a completely different
conversation because they took the time
to really make their own
battle royale and what i'm scared of
hustle and court tell me if i'm tripping
i'm scared that they're going to
do the least amount necessary remember
there was that that leak that had the
red circle that was shrinking on the map
like the regular maps we have now it was
a red circle shrinking i'm scared it's
going to be something like that i hope
that god that was fake uh people said i
remember people saying it was fake but i
never officially heard anyone but it's
just like if they do something like that
you know what i would love them to do
because of the map the way it's situated
you know how there's all those pillars
i want the map to start falling off
i don't want no circle i want those i
want the outside of the map you're you
got you got the land there and you can
literally just see it falling they could
do that
i know that's what it would make sense
because it's a ring if they did it on a
ring they could do that because ring is
detachable
and that's what i'm they have such they
have you think about the map that we're
and say zeta halo we're playing it and
we're walking through the world and you
nice trees and you've got the little
squirrels going by what about that
that's just falling out of the world it
just falls in front of you and you got
to run away you can't be hiding no bush
can't be doing any of the stuff you do
in fortnite and all that and you get hit
by that wall the world is literally
collapsing like the neverending story
it's becoming the nothing and you got to
get to that middle
then it becomes more fun how great this
stuff will be on twitch all that stuff
it would be amazing
you know what if i had the aisle because
on obs i have different uh you know you
have different prefixes that you could
have i have an iop one an attic show one
i don't know the emotes i would put on
you on to something if i had it on
i feel like that would be lit man if
they just fell off
like if if you're on guardian and you're
fighting two or three people and you
just see it and they would have to do it
like very loud like you're sitting there
and you just see like cortana or
something maybe not cortana but you hear
someone open like you're you're fall off
your ai your ai's the biggest like
lockout like out in five four and then
you just start seeing like the little
the little uh the little locks around
the map just start going up one at a
time and once they're all up it falls
oh be so and you could hear that
and then all of a sudden you just start
seeing like warthogs falling off the
side and you're just like run
it's just you gotta go oh just so good
and it would be like you could even do
teams it wouldn't even have to be a 1v1
you could have be like all right you're
fighting as teams and you're trying to
take over the center and like that's
what you're trying to do is
take the base that's in the middle but
you've all got to get there and take
over and you get oh man you can have so
much fun with it
they have this giant map and they
there's so much to do with it and they
do nothing with it so far we got a two
super chat from rdx son of fetish
halo wars 3 jazz corden says it's in
production oh i might have to talk to
him that might be a video
look i love halo wars 2. uh i didn't i
did like the multiplayer of halo wars 1
better than halo wars 2. i want them to
go back a little bit on halo wars 2. not
necessarily a whole lot i did think they
had a good balance but there were
certain things that i would have
preferred the the way they did in halo
wars 1 but halo wars 3 i'm 100 down 100
down i got like five days in that game
uh very good game
yeah it's a good game uh i think you
would enjoy it it's it's a co-op game
hustle
well i'm gonna need some help that's
where aatrox first was hustle was in
halo wars 2. yeah remember you kind of
gave me the history uh on it when um
halo was releasing um i didn't want to
say uh you know for those of you all who
are wondering about halo uh infinite in
the uh when the new battle pass drops
it's may 3rd so uh you know we'll we'll
see
yeah and i'm playing and trying to get
my well the good thing about
hey
i'm not locked in with that season pass
like i could still do the season pass
even when season two launches
so i really like it
sorry i said i really like how they did
that
i'll still be playing lego star wars
i actually i can't front on you man i've
been told by so many people that's the
best lego game that's came out in like a
decade it is i'll even go one further
it's the best star wars game that we
have ever played in a lot it's it's
it's so good i saw something just so
good i saw someone get really upset over
the title screen because um
what's her name's at the top of oh
whatever you know what look he did have
some points there man he did have some
points you know what as a star wars fan
and as an old star wars fan
shut up man complaining about the new
movie jesus christ i went through a
generation where i didn't get star wars
stuff now you're all like oh
i don't like you know what
grow up when i grew up in the 80s when
we had like we had a little bit of star
wars we're like this is awesome like oh
yeah you get nothing you get a christmas
special but it's terrible you get
nothing nothing we got cartoons we got
stuff later on but i'm talking about
these kids nowadays and everybody else
we're getting so much content all the
time
try and find some niceness in the world
stop complaining about everything oh my
god i agree there's a lot of it it's one
thing what i always have this rule court
it's one thing to speak your opinion
once
and then just move on
and especially when it comes to gaming i
feel like you could speak your opinion
once
and then
revisit it when they've had enough time
to remedy that that issue but people
that talk about the same issues every
week
they messed up they the wrong director
went in and direct in the second movie
as much i love my star wars but when
mark hamill comes out and was like
yeah i don't know why they made me throw
away that lightsaber hey that that's not
what luke skywalker would do you know
that and so then they had to try and
pigeonhole and fix it in the third one
and it was just like all right the first
one after the first one dropped we all
were like oh my god like even that
opening scene first one
it was so good it had so much homage to
everything and we were all just like and
i actually thought the third one was
good considering i agree how bad the
second one was i agreed the second one
made like derailed the whole franchise
so much
that it was a miracle they even had the
conclusion the third one had i i truly
think jj was gonna
we were gonna have two
we're gonna have more than kylo and and
and we're gonna have more jedis and it
didn't go that way and i think jj should
have just had the whole thing he knew
what he was he was doing it right it's
like when when marvel marvel finds kevin
feige and they're like you know what
just he he can pick who does what
they're gonna do
they had jj and they were like ah
let's give this other guy this other guy
did this other thing let's let him do it
and nope that just didn't work out but
unfortunately there's some good parts of
the movie i just i look at this stuff
and i'm just like i like it i don't like
it i'm like i'm just happy i'm getting
star wars yeah i agree so
i want sorry right oh no you're fine
i want to briefly talk about certain
affinity in their other project
they're making some kind of
uh monster hunter uh you know inspired
type of game um are you guys worried
that they're working on two different
projects this halo project and that
project because i feel like when you
start dividing a studio's attention uh
everything they work on starts getting
affected
100 percent he turned into platinum
games at that point right
there
is different because
certain studios will cut their attention
in half platinum cuts it in half and
cuts and then takes the other half and
cut that in half and and then take the
half that they just cut and cut that in
fourths like here i'm gonna put
something right there we never see that
other game
oh i don't think so yeah i don't know
why they need they need to they have
there it's more important to fix halo
than put out that monster hunter game
i don't know man yeah monster hunter is
a big title if they can it's a very big
title but halo is one of the biggest
titles it is
the xbox cadillac they need to fix this
i think they're going to help with
certain things but i don't think they're
going to take
like the reigns if you if you get what
i'm saying like they're going to help
them with like a little stuff but i do
think 343 is going to be doing the bulk
of the work it's just when it comes to
this game we'll have to see like
i personally would like them both even
if microsoft has to help
buy some external help to help them get
that monster hunter game out if they put
that because my thing is
certain affinity
they deserve to try it
and even if the game bombs they at least
got the opportunity yeah that's my thing
it's like i think
if that game doesn't do great
microsoft's gonna end up buying certain
affinity and they're gonna be a support
studio uh because i do feel like
microsoft has enough studios now they
don't need no more main studios they
need support studios hey you know what
we should do we should let like
sledgehammer make halo
no thank you so thank you so i kind of i
kind of had those thoughts that the
activision deal does go through i was
like because i don't i don't even know
if 343 wants to even work on halo
anymore and i say that regardless of
what bonnie ross may have said with an
interview with um
ryan mccaffrey regardless of what she
may said
i feel like creative burnout is the
thing and you know you got the mario of
of xbox for all intents and purposes
like this
there may no light shoes like there's
some big shoes to fill so
you know maybe the pressure made
pressure very well could have gotten to
them over there who knows i know i want
to speak for them and you know yeah it'd
be cool if bonnie ross sees this and she
wants to come on and you know come holla
at your boys one time
i think she kind of dope man i think
she's kind of dope and i respect that
i'm just back to ground over there but
she's a nice lady
i kind of like i do sense that she likes
games but i think she might be odd on
them at this point she's been in this
industry her whole life i feel like
she's at 343 because she's expected at
343 not because she wants to be at 343.
i think she probably wants to retire to
be honest with you i don't but i don't
know her life like that uh i was gonna
say fun fun fact um she made uh or she
had something to do with the court's uh
the kobe bryant joined on nintendo 64.
and i heard that and i had no idea um
she's playing sports too but anyway
anyway i'm going all the way off the
rails but
you know shout out to the halo infinite
man hopefully it'll you know come back
we need to make it
we need to back severely
i think i got so many games over this
joint dog that joins the gold ain't
nothing ain't nothing
they've been working on halo in this new
game for a while so i think they have a
plan in place so they're going to do
both they're going to get both done
that's right that's where my uh since of
but because the way it was described to
be this game is this game is a decent
development i don't think okay at the
beginning i don't know though because
see when you hear stuff
sometimes it could be months to six
months old
like you could hear something today
that was told to the person that told
you six months ago
and that project isn't even existing
anymore
they've cancelled it three or four
months ago but you know anyway um
i just want the whole industry to do
better i know people like to throw i
like to do the the little the little
jabby jabs with the console war stuff
but you know
i don't have a playstation with me now
my girlfriend's got it but
uh i got the xbox i have to switch i got
the playstation i like it doesn't matter
where it comes out i played fraternal i
played uh ratchet and clank i wasn't the
biggest fan of ratchet and clank i'm
ready for god of war i didn't play
horizon because i didn't like horizon
one uh i'm ready for these games man
just like i'm ready for xbox's games so
you know we're gonna go ahead and start
wrapping this up because uh hustle gotta
go take his dogs out here in a couple of
minutes actually well i gotta put my kid
to bed i'm not yeah that is like real i
gotta put my kids
where can people find you you can find
me on twitter at court leland uh you can
also find me on youtube at xbox a um a
is in you know canada take off hey yo
hosers
oh oh okay i like your background man i
like those lights and stuff like did you
make all that yourself yeah so i did but
this is this is all inspired by my
co-host matt midwood i know you guys
have had him on uh i know he's the uh
the camera expert at the iron lords
he uh his back i had a different
background before but i was always
looking at his background and i just i
got to the point where i could
i couldn't do i couldn't do it anymore i
went to ikea i got it's just ikea
cabinets you get your govi lights from
amazon that are real cheap and then i
just literally took my toys in my
consoles from back in the day and threw
them on a shelf
and it worked i think i i'm low-key
thinking about doing something like that
like not gonna lie i think that like i
wouldn't put like because i don't really
have anything like that i'll probably
buy like like gaming stuff and put it on
there i got that nes i got the the
playstation for 20 bucks
i got the nes for
uh forty dollars just the other day you
robbing people
does it work the uh nintendo i mean yes
it does
for four years
yeah that's pretty good okay so uh you
know you could go and take off court
because i know you got fans all right
thank you guys i i greatly appreciate
you having me on the show
you're fine so what about your house
where where can people catch you
we put his twitter court's twitter is in
the chat go follow him on twitter man go
over there follow that individual on
twitter
yes yes indeed now that that was funny
good cat man hey real quick before i go
it was battlefield battlefield 5 i do
believe i had zero kills i swear to god
i had zero kills but my score was higher
than the person who had four who went
41-2
no cap no cabinet which i'll put a
screenshot in the post and joins the
twitter that happens a lot
that happens a lot more on battlefield
than you think that happens a lot more
on battlefield than you think hey um no
eric empire and ricky and the
troubleshooters they were telling me
they said yo it really rewards you for
being support and being a good teammate
i was like yo i i like that dream right
that's that's kind of why i wanted to
play a 20-42 but i did anyway look
i will be playing
kingdom hearts at some point i'll
probably i'll probably start this friday
more than likely i'll have to see um i
probably won't stream it i have a video
that um that i'm working on i got a
couple videos i'm working on but uh the
last of this video that i said i was
working on i'm actually play the game
over again someone clean footage i don't
want to use the footage that i had
before so i may just upload some stuff
in the meantime
i'll say that um i'm doing good man like
yo thank whoever i guess y'all in the
chat shout out for to y'all for like
supporting my ninja turtles video it's
almost at like 400 views and if you
don't know what i'm talking about hold
on because if you don't know what i'm
talking about i'm gonna go ahead and
link that video as well um
i feel good i can't wait for stratos
revenge if we're being completely honest
i am six or i'm three subs away from 600
so you know it's up to me if you haven't
please please up to me on my youtube
channel if you haven't and watch my
latest video here
i'm just going to put a joint up link
get in front of me next hold on
there we go
there we go
so go ahead oh yeah that's right suppose
your boy one time what's this
just keep keep talking what kingdom
hearts did i play first i mean you told
me birth by sleep so i don't we gonna
let them choose you're gonna have to
tell me so i have no idea um yeah but
y'all y'all go ahead and you know give
your boy a follower i'm i'm close i'm
close to a thousand subs than i was
yesterday so
we almost there are we almost there um
sunday should be the next time i post
the video so y'all be on the lookout for
that
and um attic where can the good folks
find you sir
you can find me on twitter at lord
addict iop
give me one second because i do want to
i completely forgot when he left it
messed up the uh the template
oh the boxes yeah yeah yeah you can
follow me on twitter laura addict iop
you can find me on youtube at gaming
attic now i'm probably going to change
things up over there on youtube a little
bit
uh i don't know how i'm going to do it
yet we got a five dollar sweep chat from
hustle hustle i hope uh your last of us
is about how much better two is than the
slightly above average one
what do you say uh
yeah you know i see it now i see it
i'm not going to slam the last of us too
because i haven't played it yet but hey
look i asked i asked someone on um on
twitter earlier today i said hey
is there there's a gold filter
apparently i said hey is there a
brutality filter they told me no so i i
don't know if i can i don't know if my
my sensitive heart can handle that king
said he cried like three times playing
that joint dog i ain't trying to be no
big mess around here king of king is a
cancer like myself i think his birthday
is like a week after mine
i'll be a whole mess trying to like do a
show though i don't know man i don't
know what we're gonna have to do hustle
to get the subscriber count up is get
you on for that e3 uh for that microsoft
prediction show that's one of our
biggest shows a year
i'll make sure on there i'll make sure
i'm there
all right so uh you know
how people vote for kingdom on over i
don't know man uh but it's up to him in
general uh the the realm with the 10
votes thinks you should play kingdom
hearts one first
are you going to be streaming this or is
this something you're just going to play
i think i'm just going to play it all
right yeah so i think i'm just going to
come here you know we'll talk about it
we'll dedicate like 10 minutes of the
show to it every day how he likes it
what uh worlds he's playing now keep in
mind these will be spoilers obviously
these games came out years ago and most
of you in the chat hate this damn game
anyway there's 1587 people in the chat
definitely that like button if you guys
don't mind man uh you know it's hard to
get that algorithm as a podcast unless
people like the podcast but anyway i
appreciate everyone for coming through
uh you know go follow
subscribe to uh hustle on youtube i try
to get him up as much as we possibly can
let's try to get you at 500 by uh by
next month let's try to get you 500 by
next month hey we'll see let's see i'll
just work hard you know how that go all
right so
hold up
so without any further ado man we'll see
you next week on tuesday at 5 p.m
because of this whole shenanigans going
on with well it's not shenanigans i'm
going to packs next week so we have to
do it a little bit early uh so we will
have the show next week tuesday 5 p.m i
will put it on twitter and i'll announce
it on iop i gotta communicate with my
guest for next week to see to make sure
he can make it tuesday because i forgot
i will be gone wednesday i leave
wednesday morning i forgot i'll be gone
so we'll have a tuesday but anyway
appreciate ever coming through this
gaming action hustle and motivate and
we'll talk to you next week